I give this to you because Sammy's
sitting and diving is my family being a
student-athlete has taught me a lot
about hard work and dedication to the
team and I give because I hope that
students will be able to experience the
same family that I have here at CMU the
County Mellon International Film
Festival allows me to combine my studies
and business here at tempered with my
lifelong passion for film build
incredible events that allow the
community of Pittsburgh to come together
and watch films from different countries
and talk about them when I get to CMU I
hope it takes students like me and helps
them find their passion whether that's
within their study or far beyond it CNU
gave me a life-changing experience by
sending me to the Grace Hopper
celebration of women in computing it was
absolutely incredible seeing
trailblazers and women in tech who were
still willing to fight until there's a
place for all of us in this industry I
get to CMU because this place has given
me the confidence and has reassured me
that people like me can belong in tech
and we should belong into it my
involvement at CMU hello has showed me
the impact that giving can have a
student can come to CMU Hillel on a
Friday night enjoy a delicious meal
celebrate their Jewish identity learn
about Judaism and this could last for
students both now and well into the
future
I give to CMU to give thanks for all
that CMU has given me I give to CMU
because I care a lot about my home
department of civil environmental
engineering it's a very small enclosed
community of people and they've really
helped me grow as a person
I just appreciate that a lot and want to
be able to give back to them our
graduation is approaching is to join me
and giving back to Carnegie Mellon and
the students following in your footsteps
this is your chance to leave your mark
on the University we love make a gift of
five dollars or more and it will count
toward your senior class gift every gift
impacts
lives to support an area of CMU close to
your heart maybe a college or school a
student organization or scholarships
when you give you're helping other
students like you reach their goals and
pursue a world-class education you can
make a difference get where you love and
empower the next generation of Tartans
to change the world
[Music]